[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kisser
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guest this week is a
wonderful comedian Jeff norco professor
of politics at Birkbeck University in
London Eric Cartman the spike columnist
and the author of what women want fun
freedom and an end to feminism Ella
Whelan Mike Goodwin who's a professor of
political science at the University of
Kent and a senior fellow at Chatham
House Matt welcome trigonometry
[Music]
national populism is obviously we've
seen a rice how much of that has got to
do with the economic crash in 2008 hmm
well this is a million dollar question
right so if you're on the Left you
basically argue and I'm not some peeking
judgments I don't know where your
politics are got an idea but if you if
you lean left words you tend to say all
of this is about economic scarcity right
it's the old Marxist line that
effectively anybody who votes for
nationalist movements or movements that
express unease about mass immigration
that they are driven by their worries
over basically income wages and and
scarce economic goods and usually an
extension of their argument is that the
people are being manipulated by ruthless
elites in society whether it's the media
whether it's these conspiratorial you
know right-wingers trying to divide and
rule the evidence I would argue and
certainly we argue in the book is pretty
overwhelming and pointing in a different
direction which is that if you think for
example about some of the most
successful national populace that we've
had in the Western world coming in
places like Switzerland in Austria the
Netherlands they broke through amid very
low unemployment rate some of the lowest
unemployment rates in Europe very strong
growing economies look at law and
justice in Poland really came into power
on the back of a rapid economic
expansion take Britain Nigel Farage in
the UK Independence Party first really
broke through in 2004 after 48
consecutive periods of growth and then
when we drill down to the individual
level and we look at who's actually
supporting these movements and we sure
will come back to it they tend to be
working full-time they tend to often be
on not amazing wages but you know
standard average wages and so the
unemployed the kind of real losers of
globalization in a sort of visceral
sense they are not generally providing
the bulk of support to national populism
and he is worth remembering even in
nineteen in the 1930s many people on the
left like that comparison at the moment
a lot of the unemployed and those who
are out of work or actually voting for
the communist not for the
the National Socialists and National
Socialism national populism the two very
different movements but the idea that
the left push is that this is all about
economic scarcity I'm afraid is not
actually very convincing when you look
at the evidence one of the interesting
points in the book is that one of the in
fact you cite in the book is that Donald
Trump voters on had the average highest
income of the three available candidates
which he'd take Bernie Sanders Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump his vote has
actually had a higher average income
than any of the other two and I wanted
to come back to the fact that you've
been talking about this for a long time
actually you've been predicting this
unlike most people who predicted brexit
and Trump very confidently after it
happened right you actually predicted
that many years before you've been
talking about this since like 2010 at
least from what I've seen in interviewed
with economist for example where you
were talking actually about Anders
Breivik I think in the context of this
and that is not a time in which we were
having these conversations at all so can
you take us back through that period if
it's not the economic crash that Francis
asked you about what has happened over
the last 10 to 15 years that has caused
this movement to emerge in this way yeah
well one of my pet frustrations about
the public debate is that we focus on
the short term factors right and we
obsessed about what happens during
campaigns I mean I just finished reading
Hillary Clinton's book what happened and
I realized she still doesn't know what
happens because she's obsessed with what
what happened during that campaign
period now I would say actually if you
don't if you look not that the last 10
to 15 years but actually the last 30 to
40 years you can really see a number of
deep currents begin to come forward and
start to reshape democracies in the West
quietly but in a powerful way from below
creating the conditions that have
allowed national populism today to get
to the levels of support that with that
we're seeing and this is partly about a
backlash to the rise of what you might
call the new left in the 60s and the 70s
which pushed a very liberal agenda the
expansion of rights for minorities the
support if not celebration of
mass immigration the shift towards
supranational institutions like the
European Union and in the 80s and the
90s and particularly in countries like
France and Austria you began to see the
beginnings of a backlash to that new
liberal consensus jean-marie lepen for
example he used to run on the slogan
lepen of the people yeah or the Austrian
freedom party in York Haider an earlier
generation of populist that we now tend
to forget because we like to think
everything is unique to our era
jörg Haider used to say I say what the
people think right and it was that
notion that he's tapping into a concern
particularly among a lot an alliance of
social conservatives that were often
quite affluent and blue-collar workers
who together felt very uncomfortable
with both the scale and the pace of
change that was happening within the
broader nation and that was partly about
immigration it was also about in some
countries increasingly a political
establishment that seemed to be holding
the people in contempt certainly
neglecting them and also increasingly in
more recent years the specific issue of
Islam in Europe and the refugee crisis
that followed so by the time you get to
really the 90s or 2000s and you guys
start going through things like 9/11
long before the financial crisis you're
beginning to see these movements
actually reaching very high levels of
support in some countries joining
national governments often doing well
and very prosperous affluent areas and
really winning over low-skilled service
workers the self-employed blue-collar
workers so we talk a lot about the
collapse of social democracy today
actually you can really be traced that
to the early to mid 2000s and now the
crisis kicked in and no one's saying the
crisis isn't important because it is and
it wasn't the underlying driver but it
did exacerbate a number of these
emerging value conflicts in the West
between kind of culturally liberal
middle class professionals and those
social conservatives and workers and you
begin to see this kind of gradual
polarization within a lot of Western
democracies and I think what mattered in
a big way was
the National populace themselves also
changed they became more articulate they
became more sophisticated they started
to tone down white supremacism they
started to basically get a bit more in
line with where public opinion really
was on these issues
people like builders started to say well
let's be pro LGBT but also let's be anti
Islam at the same time so you started to
see these kind of curious innovations
that we didn't really have before and of
course that then really brought together
you know the public demand for a sort of
a challenge to that liberal consensus
with this sort of party supply with
these parties just being a bit more
competent a bit more articulate at how
they're bringing these groups into the
political system and today where we are
you know I think the interesting macro
question at least is when you look at
what's happening in the West there's
this signal that we are at the end of a
period of great change and volatility
well does it instead signal that we are
at the beginning of a new period of
great change fragmentation and
polarization my view is that if you look
at all the evidence we are very much at
the beginning of a new period of great
change and volatility
[Music]
we talked about brexit the majority
position is the one that's demonized
which is quite incredible in and of
itself so when you talk about most
people think this I think there's so
many issues on which most people think
something and that is the position that
is demonized which is incredible place
to be isn't it yeah but it shows how
completely out of step the political
establishment and to a certain degree
the media are with public opinion so the
fact that I mean I was a break steer and
and I see that as a pretty standard
left-wing position but the fact is the
vote was announced and then I think it
was probably bout 45 minutes afterwards
we got to celebrate in the spiked office
for about half an hour and then we were
right right we're on the defensive and
the other biggest political mandate in
British history has been systematically
demonized I like viciously demonized
for two years straight or whatever point
we're at now and I think that isn't
coming from people people aren't
stopping levers in the street and
hurling eggs that they've been saying
like you've put the country to hell
it's MPs and its political commentators
who are really viciously against prexy I
think that tells you about the
separation it's going on the kind of big
lines in the sand between those who are
the rulers and who make the laws and
those of us who are ruled to a
sentencing one interesting about braces
is we get quite a lot of comments and in
particular comedians who are sort of
that sort of very the left so korbinite
left and they the criticism that they
always put to me is you never get any
left-wing people on and I say actually
we do but a lot of them support brexit
and a lot of scene people seem to think
that in order for you to support bricks
that you need to be on the right but
that's obviously a fallacy because
there's a lot of people on the left
especially were you consider to be the
old-school Tony Benn esque left they all
support brexit or of large majority of
Robin does as well but yes yeah he does
he's just not honest about
no he isn't on a [ __ ] he's gonna sold
out whose side of the left emulation -
breaks it I guess it's because the main
leave campaign the main phases of it
were Tory MPs or they don't think you
can necessarily call them rabid right
wingers but there wasn't a vocal left
for breaks it other than spikes we had a
sore as because we could be our campaign
and he had some labor left people who
camp of campaign for break sir but on
the whole there wasn't a coherent
left-wing movement for what I thought
was this great opportunity to break
through years of mush and status quo and
not moving anywhere in politics then you
have this moment where lots of
working-class people are saying we want
to change in politics and we want to
have a greater say and we want to shake
things up and the lesson nowhere to be
seen so not that I revel in the fact
that that is the case but I think it
tells you a lot about where the left is
today if they were so blind as to not
see this as an opportunity to change
politics quite dramatically I mean I
remember in the two weeks after the vote
you had news about how the Tory party
was going to disintegrate about how
labour was going to disintegrate
Westminster was crumbling everyone was
falling apart and I was like yes this is
what I vote for this is great I mean you
know I never have voted in general
elections when I was young gross to
spoil my ballot and then my mum was said
they never read the like essay that you
write you know they just see that you
haven't taken the book so anyway and I
and that was a conscious decision
because I thought none of these people
represent what I want in any way shape
or form I'm very very against picking
the best of a bad bunch but brexit was
the first thing ever in my political
career where I was like right this is
something I definitely know that I care
about I'm 107 behind this let's go and
that was I think that was a lot of
people's experience I mean the voter
turnout for breaks it was ginormous in
comparison to general elections
and you see then the general action
after it numbers completely tanked again
which tells you what you need to know
about how important this thing was and
how tragic I think it is that it's being
slammed to such a great extent
[Music]
a lot of the the media narrative around
populism immediately after say the Trump
or brexit vote
turn to you know who voted for Trump or
who voted for brexit and where do they
live and you can see that the cities
tended to be say remain voting and
outlying areas tended to be for leave
and those areas tend to be a bit more
deprived so people kind of jump to these
conclusions well it's the people the
left behind they're the ones who voted
to leave or they voted for Trump the
problem with that of course is that you
know just take London as a city it's
gone a large number of people who are
not white British it's got a large
number of people with university degrees
a large number of young people so that
makes it fairly unusual demographically
the only real way to do that study
properly is to take a white
working-class person in London and a
white working-class person in the north
you know in a mining town for example
and compare them and when you do that
you actually see if anything that person
in London is slightly more likely to
have voted leave so that's the kind of
method where you're actually looking at
individuals individual level large-scale
survey data not looking at these
election maps are talking about opioid
crises or so on so yeah the first
takeaway really is that it's almost all
about immigration when we talk about
right-wing populism not left wing
populism podemos and Korb and that is
about the economy but right wing
populism in the West not again in India
or in even in Eastern Europe in the West
it's about immigration and the actual
academic literature is actually pretty
solid on this as well the academic
literature shows this and wouldn't
dispute this now some of course would
dispute it but certainly when it comes
to immigration a lot of the academic
there was a meta-analysis done which is
an analysis of all the literature and
they they find essentially that how poor
you are whether you're unemployed or not
whether you've lost your job those are
not things that predict your immigration
attitudes and these are not things that
are driving right-wing populism so the
mainstream narrative right now is
essentially people have nothing to to
live on the people don't have a job like
you say and they're lashing out against
immigrants because that's where we
normally channel anger when we've lost
out and one whatever and you say well I
say no I say essentially what this is
about
is anxiety over ethnic cultural change
threats to identity I mean I'll give you
a kind of question that we might ask
people say in this country we ask brexit
ears in white British brexit ears how
concerned are you how much of a problem
is pressure on public services 0 to 100
hundred being it's a big problem and
people give it about a 40 and brexit
leave early voters give it about a 47 48
out of a hundred and all you have to do
is stick the word immigrants putting
pressure on public services is the same
question how much of a problem is
pressure on public services but it's
immigrants putting just two words
pressure on public services it goes from
sort of 48 out of a hundred to 70 out of
100 for remainders it's the reverse and
actually makes sense what the remainders
are doing actually does make sense
because if the problem is pressure on
public services the part of that problem
that is accounted for by immigrants has
to be smaller than the problem itself so
it makes no sense to get a number moving
from say 48 up to 70 because the problem
is the immigrant fueled part of the
problem cannot be larger than the whole
problem but that's just a way of my way
of explaining that this is not driven by
people's worry about pressure on public
service as economic things which is sort
of the narrative of probably both
parties in a way because that's what
they know they've got economic policy
tools it's also safer because we can
talk about well people are feeling
pressure on material things schools and
hospitals and that's why they're upset
about immigration it's not that nasty
cultural stuff but actually it is that
cultural stuff well let's break that
down when you say the nasty cultural
stuff right what you're not I've read
your book very carefully so you're not
saying that the majority of the people
who are on the populace right
hey immigrants and their racist right
you're not I think that's I'm not saying
that no I actually think we need to open
up a conversation about white identity
first of all and secondly something I
call the white tradition of national
identity and to do so in a fair-minded
way so there is a certain kind of
toxicity around the subject
of white group identity by Mitchell
[Laughter]
people together we identify for being
white it tends to end in camps and well
no III disagree with you so for example
I don't think identifying as white or
identifying as black or identifying is
Hawaiian you know we have to look at
these things differently I mean all of
those identities can be abused you can
go you can fixate and be extremist about
it but just if you think about the world
you know 80% of the world's countries
have an ethnic majority you know some
Persians in Iran and could be SWANA in
Botswana Japanese in Japan etc those
those P know these people identify with
their group with their culture and
they're not out killing each other now
some well but when we think about what
are the predictors of genocide for
example it's it's an it's an ideology
that says this country should only be
inhabited by either a particular group
or people who adhere to an ideology like
socialism or like Islam Islamism and if
you don't adhere to that you're in the
way we're gonna exterminate you so it
doesn't necessarily matter whether it's
a particular aside entity like ethnicity
or it's a universalist identity like
Islam or socialism there are extreme
versions and moderate versions and you
can have a moderate version of white
identity as you can a moderate version
of Islamic identity and there's nothing
wrong with that and that's sort of the
normal state of affairs in most
countries most of the time so I think
this focus on white identity is toxic
actually doesn't have a basis in fact
even though we know yes we're all lost
relatives in the Holocaust you know yes
of course but that's one case and we
actually have to say okay all of the
countries in the world that have ethnic
majorities that identify with their
group and then all of the places in the
world that have a genocidal event and we
have datasets actually where we can look
at this question systematically and we
find well actually you have to have a
number of conditions in place one of
which is this
exclusivist focus on identity till it's
not just saying you know we are Hindus
in India but it's you know everybody who
isn't a Hindu is garbage and must be
exterminated that's that's a very
different thing from just saying we
identify as Hindu so you can have
moderate versions and extreme versions
of any identity whether it's a minority
identity or a majority so I really think
actually we have to start to think about
it being you know okay to express a
moderate white identity or what I mean
by that is ethnic majority identity
because again eighty percent of the
world's countries have these ethnic
majority identities if we try and say
you can't have that I actually think we
are making things worse if anything I
think that's the greater risk then if we
say okay it can be expressed but it's
got to be done in a moderate way
[Music]
you've never felt like you do prague
brexit material yes especially in
someone in London
yeah and just feel you lose wherever you
go but wherever you go there were a lot
of people devoted leave I mean this is
one of the weird things about it you
know with the sheer numbers game you
know you talk about in London you know
was it 37 percent voted leave I mean if
you was in using a room of a hundred
people I am 37 of them voted leave 63 of
them voted that would feel like a lot of
people and in some ways at times you
won't be able to tell the difference of
you know just looking around on a pure
optics level who's in the majority here
so there's always a lot of people data
most of them don't give as much of a
[ __ ] as we do you know in the comedy
game a lot of them most people of
reasonable people you know the remain is
that you hear on Lyon moment the old
true Mainers are exactly that most
people are happy to have the piss taken
out of them and the other thing is is
it's not pro brexit material as such I
think that it's very hard to do any
comedy about something were you saying I
really believe in this man and here's
some jokes about what I believe it I
mean comedy almost exclusively is comes
from what you think is [ __ ] you know so
so it's aiming the satirical fire back
at the you know the remain way of
thinking and I think that I mean a
simple rule I have is like satire is
always possible as if it's the three
ages right hysteria hypocrisy and
hyperbole right now if you think about
all those things and you look at you
know some wings of the romaine cap you
know hypocrisy they become like each
other that's what so what you know I
think ultra might remain errs have
become exactly and maybe that's what you
sometimes I say two defeats I mean you
have to become the beast in order to be
here but you think you sometimes think
do you realize what what you're saying
here do you realize how [ __ ] mental
it sounds with you and I think that I
think the one bit of project fear that
has worked actually I think a lot of it
failed miserably but I think the thing
of making it seem like a no deal breaks
it is actually the cliff edge I think
that that's actually worked for most
people you know for the remain camp the
languages stuff isn't it you know a
cliff edge breaks it crashing out of the
EU there was an interesting stat about
you know they talk about the reduction
in GDP against
again because it's not actually
reduction in GDP is against what Britain
would have otherwise had so the worst
case scenario right was over 15 years
this is more carnage prediction so you
know this was pessimistic I mean it's
like that keys inside you it was raining
you're going and I'll just check out the
window you know yes but he said it'd be
7.7 percent lower over 15 years now that
roughly works out about half a percent
of GDP a year now anything that's not
obviously that's a big sum of money it
could build hospitals and schools would
the average punter recognize that year
in year out I don't know you know but
they've been quite successful we can't
rate in that sort of environment that
since effect
well actually the stats show that about
70% of leave voters would happily
sacrifice a chunk of their income
yeah and for example reducing
immigration yes yeah and then take him
back well I mean the top thing in the
law - cough pal Wars was sovereignty
wasn't it right self-determination in a
pure sense but that is one thing right
and I had this chat with the producer
the master port Christo who's a hardier
and Maya a really good blow you know we
just we just I said it's the one thing
like he does understand you know at
least he's honest about it I just don't
get it I just don't get it as a
principle when you think you in a way
you have to respect that there's two
years on it if people don't understand
sort of total the self-determination now
they know they never will and I think
though you know they'll say things old
but we do serve you don't because
there's things that we can't do as a
country and I think that immigration was
interesting because like it's always
perceived that that if you was if he was
against freedom of movement that's
because you wanted really low
immigration it's not for a lobby was
certainly myself it wasn't that it was
just just seemed quite an absolute ism
you know freedom of movement in
perpetuity for all time you think that
you know in that any nation state
shouldn't be allowed to you know sort of
appropriate their needs based on what
was happening in their country at that
point I just thought it was strange that
that was was was decided centrally you
know and also you know when it comes to
immigration he sometimes for a long time
now in Britain people have been able to
cut the successive governments being
able to go well you know they it makes
it a negative thing doesn't it we go
well you know the EU it's better for us
freedom of movement is just one of those
things that comes with you know goes
with the territory whereas if you
actually take responsibility for the
amount of migrants coming here you
actually have to sell it to the public
in a positive way you know one of the
reasons that the Windrush scandal had
broad sort of sympathy from the public
is that was how that was sold to the
British people at the time people to
come into Britain because we need these
people to come and do our jobs whereas
for too long now it's just been seen as
one of these unfortunate byproducts of
being part of the EU well that's what I
was going to say I'm an immigrant here
right you know Francis mother who came
here as well to this country I don't
understand how they've created this
cultural meme in society that if you
want to control or reduce immigration
that's racist
I don't I don't demand how that I mean
there's no doubt this some people don't
do it I just want to end it off you know
but the I think there was that watershed
moment wasn't there to remember with
Gordon Brown and there was that there
was a woman who nothing yeah and she's
spoken about a lot of different things
you know a lot of stuff that was very
primary HS and then she ended it by
saying something about immigration they
called her an awful woman I don't think
it was like you know things were
changing very fast
you know the labor government had sort
of underestimated you know the impact of
it and I don't miss a thing it
necessarily comes from a place of total
cynicism but but they just had an
legislators it's a way of filing it away
isn't it well if you've got any concerns
about migration whatsoever then then
you're a racist and you know the problem
is it just breeds a backlash right and
and I think that you know I think I
think that for this economy of this
country to be successful with a will bit
need to be you know of course nobody but
no one ever said migration was was
ending but again that's one I suppose
that's one of the remain bits of
hyperbole that that has stuck the idea
that you know people who say oh I won't
be able go and work in Europe now you go
you know yet relative of yours have
worked in the United States right that's
not pause you know they use so these
things will be possible admittedly they
might be slightly more dim but they're
you know bit more forms to fill out and
stuff and it might be as guaranteed but
but yeah the absolutism has been has
been quite Jory well listen guys if
you've enjoyed it this week as I'm sure
you have subscribers over to our channel
click that Bell button next to subscribe
button on YouTube so you get notified
when we release a video I do want to do
the so for me just
yes yep if so if you're enjoying it
please follow us on trigger pod at
Instagram on Twitter trigonometry on
Facebook and athlete let's get the
server that's it see you next week bye
bye